we want to feel safe at work which means
we feel that we can be ourselves it
means that we feel safe enough to raise
our hands and say I made a mistake or I
don't feel qualified for the position
you've given me I need more training or
I'm struggling at home it's affecting my
work I'm scared I need help
to say any of those things with the
confidence that our boss or any of our
colleagues would rush to support us
because if we don't create those
psychologically and sometimes physically
safe spaces but this psychological safe
space is what we end up is with a group
of people who come to work every day
lying hiding and faking their hiding
mistakes they are not admitting if they
don't know how to do their jobs they
will never admit that they don't know
something for fear that it makes them
vulnerable for fear that it maybe makes
them the weak link that they'll find
themselves on some shortlist at the next
round of layoffs and the problems is how
do you run a successful organization
that's supposed to sustain over the long
term thrive over the long term if people
are literally hiding things that go
wrong not admitting that they don't know
how to do their jobs and never admitting
they need help that doesn't last that
doesn't last and the problem is is when
someone leads with a finite mindset
where their attempt to incentivize
performance and by the way you can't
incentivize performance you can only
incentivize behavior then bad things
eventually happen
[Music]